Recently, there was some leaked footage from
the owner of the Miss Universe Organization,
and in it, the owner said,
we're going to accept everything.
Trans women,
married women, fat women.
But they don't understand.
They think if I can compete,
I can win between us.
We know they can compete,
but they can't win.
As a married woman who competes in pageants
and is actually a titleholder right now,
I have some thoughts about this,
and they might not be what you think.
I am not at all surprised by this.
Back last year,
when the Miss Universe Organization announced that it
was going to start allowing married women to compete
and that there was no longer going to be an age limit,
I remember a lot of people around me celebrating
and being excited
and even, like,
nudging me, being like,
are you gonna compete in it?
And I just remember kind of thinking
it felt patronizing.
It felt funny.
If any person can compete and be Miss Universe,
like, what does Miss Universe even mean?
Nowadays, we are terrified of the word exclusion, right?
But we don't realize that organizations,
businesses, teams,
they exclude all the time.
Take Major League Baseball,
for example.
By its very nature,
it excludes everybody who isn't amazing at baseball.
It is very, very exclusive.
And I could never be in the MLB,
and that's okay.
Exclusion is everywhere,
and that's sometimes okay.
It would be so refreshing to see a business
Or an organization
kind of own that and say, yes,
we are the Miss Universe Organization.
You must be a miss to compete.
Most of us would be absolutely okay with that.
Like, just be honest.
Just own who you are.
I'm a married woman.
I am excluded from the Miss Universe pageant.
That only makes sense.
And that's okay.
I can go in the Mrs. Pageant.
I can do a bunch of other things. It's okay.
But a lot of businesses and a lot of organizations
do this as kind of a virtue signal, right?
To be like, look at us,
we are so inclusive.
And after a while,
it just starts to feel foamy and patronizing.
And the only difference
between the Miss Universe Organization
and a lot of other companies and businesses
is that Miss Universe got caught.